but our boys they're on equal points  then going into the last round  yeah yeah no no i'm absolutely fine with  of course the more drama the better for  us  i mean i'm also now i'm very much  looting for jan but okay he's sharing  first  place  he has everything in his own hands  magnus is fighting like hell  that's how it has to be  that's how it has to be and fabi is  there as well  so yeah absolutely crazy i think it's  pity that it's only thirteen launch so  give give us fifteen two more guys  that's true  give us also uh but he's not gonna win  against daniel  but i will i perfectly understand the  players if if they tell i mean wasn't it  enough i mean certain bloody runs  this is the elementary  the rook on g7 get out of the way go h7  well but it's it's a big question uh  what what will happen that i and abdul  also shares that yeah i was shaking  himself  yeah  congratulations for magnus i mean  again winning the fantastic technical  game